I think when people hear this they're
like wait what now once again we return
to
MSNBC and Jen staki here she has Karen
Dunn talking about how it's uh White
supremacists at those Pro Hamas rallies
I did not know that I just want to start
with because I think when people hear
this they're like wait what why are
white supremacists showing up at these
Pro Palestinian rallies what do they
want out of this well overall Jen and
thanks for having me uh what they want
is they want an all-white ethnos state
in North America and as crazy as that
sounds that's actually an articulated
goal of the Neo-Nazi and white
supremacist movement in the US and one
of the things that helps them rally the
troops uh is anti-Semitism so now in the
US we're experiencing a massive uptick
in anti-Semitism incidents are up
something like 388 per and the white
supremacists Neo-Nazi groups see an
opportunity to advance some of the same
themes some of the same anti anetic
tropes that they've been plugging away
at for
years I don't know what she is talking
about I mean I understand that she's
making up a story that there are white
supremacists at the pramas rallies but
we've looked at a lot of the videos we
couldn't find any neo-nazis there uh if
you can find neo-nazis hanging out with
the brown Arab people screaming kill the
Jews generally generally speaking
neo-nazis let's say white supremacists
who want white people to reign supreme
uh they don't hang out with a lot of
brown people who many of whom are
illegal in the country that would be
considered and that yeah you know I was
doing the math earlier it's a little
confusing so there's literally no
evidence of that but you can see exactly
what they want the brainwashed
non-playable characters who watch MSNBC
to think oh my God it's not the brown
people who are screaming from The River
To The Sea and Hitler is great and kill
all the Jews it's not those guys are the
bad guys it's the white people who are
with
them